metropolitan police have launched a
murder investigation after a 21 year old
man was stabbed to death at the notting
hill carnival in london
a number of violent incidents broke out
including several serious stabbings
marring the end of the festival which
was attended by around about a million
people the police extended their stop
and search powers in the area around
notting hill last night and officers are
appealing to carnival goers to come
forward with information
joining us now is minister of state for
department digital culture media and
sport which is a bit of a mouthful isn't
it matthew warman let's call him that
instead should we good morning to you
just a thought on what happened at
nottingham hill to start with well it's
obviously a tragic event and to have
seen so many people out trying to have
a lovely time on a bank holiday weekend
to have ended in in this way for at
least one individual is obviously a
tragedy but as you see the police are
making some progress and i just concur
with their uh appeal to people if
they've got any information to get in
touch okay thank you
um talk to us about the cost of living
crisis if you would obviously we'll have
more from notting hill throughout the
course of the programme
um we got the price cap figure didn't we
3549
pounds what we that was from afghan what
we didn't get is a plan from the
government
well i think what you've seen is a
significant amount of help already up to
1200 pounds and sometimes beyond for
people who need it most and this will
absolutely be at the top of the next
prime minister's in trey as well so
there's help there and there is i'm sure
going to be help to come you acknowledge
that much more needs to be done i think
it's obvious that the package that was
put forward a few weeks ago was done in
slightly different circumstances and i
think that's why you've seen both
leadership candidates lay out uh to some
extent uh the fact that some more needs
to be done yes what are we waiting for
well it's right i think when we have a
prime minister due to be uh put in place
a new prime minister due to be put in
place uh on monday then it's going to be
for them to make uh the detailed plans
that people need to see i think that's
that's a fair and sensible process why
minister why is that
well i think the prime minister when he
stood down acknowledged that he wasn't
still prime minister he is still prime
minister and that's why he and nadim
sahar we have been working on uh what
the options might be but i do think it's
only fair and reasonable that someone
who is going to take over in less than a
week's time
has the right to say this is how i think
it's best to take the country forward
through what are going to be immensely
challenging time the reason is i i make
the point i think i'm writing saying
that you support rishi sooner
um he's talked about hundreds of pounds
being made available but you know what
what does that actually mean people who
are watching this morning who saw that
that price cap had gone up to more than
three and a half thousand pounds uh last
friday are wondering how they're going
to keep their kids warm this winter yeah
and you're absolutely right lots of
people i've had lots of constituents uh
in touch individuals what are they just
those
sorts of worries and what they're saying
is that they're worried about the
uncertainty of what winter is going to
look like and of course they've seen
those headlines about the new
cap i think for me the most important
thing is that we target those who need
it most we target the most vulnerable
that's what you saw in that package that
differentiates between
some people who have greater needs than
others but acknowledge that everybody
needs help so what constitutes the most
vulnerable well i think pensioners in
particular those on fixed incomes
obviously we need to think about that we
need to think about people who are
particularly reliant on benefits but the
fact is as we heard from the chancellor
not long ago this is something that is
going to affect people somewhat higher
up the income scale as well and that's
why the principles of the package that
was announced before i think are the
right ones which are to focus the help
on those who need it most but also to
acknowledge that a degree of
universality is the right one so
middle-income families can expect
support as well well as i say that will
be a matter for the new prime minister
but middle income families got some
support already when rishi soon act was
chancellor i would think that those
principles should be continued yeah just
looking at i mean what the french are
doing and what the spanish are doing
they've already come up with quite a lot
of support for for people who live in
those countries including um a four
percent uh freeze as far as the french
concern i think edf one of their um
one of their energy companies as you
know they're taking an 8.4 billion pound
hit spain's agreed to a price cap as
well and tax cuts as well
we are just waiting until we see who the
next prime minister is well i think
you've already seen a windfall tax
you've already seen that significant
package of support i don't disagree with
you that there needs to be
more to come and that's why both
leadership candidates have been talking
about it to such an extent already and
it's why from the prime minister on
sunday you saw that article talking
about uh what uh this government has
been doing and what more needs to happen
as well under his successes would you
support a freeze in the energy price cap
well i think it it partly depends on
what you mean by that but ultimately
what it is the price of fuel can't go up
any higher of energy can't go up any
higher than what it is uh at the moment
it's been set at 3549 pounds which which
is already a significant rise which has
been offset uh to some extent by uh the
package that rishi sunak announced what
i support is something that really does
as i say target those people who are
most vulnerable who need it most but
also acknowledges that there are people
who are somewhat higher up that income
scale that are going to need genuine
help so i'm sorry did you say that you
were supporting and freezing the energy
price no what as i say what what i
support is something that a drill a lot
of the energy companies are of course
aren't they that's what the energy
bosses are well so i think this needs to
be something that tackles uh both the
energy supply and energy security
challenges that we've got and tackles
the problems that people have as
individuals paying their own bills there
are a number of different policy ways
you might try and get to that conclusion
and as i say it is right that the next
prime minister makes those decisions
perhaps if we'd had a prime minister
before now then we wouldn't still be
waiting for what
he or she is going to do
i don't make the rules on how long it's
taken to go through this contest but i
think
personally i would have preferred it had
it taken somewhat less time yes and i
think
when the party considers what the rules
might look like going forward
that will i suspect be something that
many people will take an interest in but
that's not a problem that we can address
right now we've got less than a week
until the new prime minister is in place
in fact yeah next monday you quite right
fifth of september we should find out
who that is i suppose an easy way around
that would have been for your man to
have pulled out before now
well i think uh rishi is still fighting
absolutely for every vote you're seeing
him going out and meeting huge numbers
of party members right even
up to this moment and i think that this
is if you're going to have a contest it
is sensible to have a contest it was
widely pointed out before boris johnson
stood down how disruptive this process
would be that is deeply regrettable and
it's not more true now than ever
but i do think as i say less than a week
to go it is what it is right now um how
are you looking back on his reign
i think well for instance one of the
reasons why i'm out today is talking
about huge growth in broadband uh uh
that was my cue
provision exactly
so i think there's lots of things i in
my own constituency we're getting a huge
new a e there are lots of things under
that leveling up agenda uh that boris
johnson i think we'll look back on and
be hugely proud of and that broadband
announcement uh today we've hit 70
gigabit capable uh premises uh today
that's up from nine percent in 2019
that's a huge shift in a very short
period and it comes from the focus that
number 10 delivered why can i never get
internet on the train then minister
internet coverage on railways is a
particular challenge some of it is down
to the design physically of the railways
we have again made huge progress on that
and partly i've never noticed it well
partly we've put it into the contracts
of the trade at the train operating
companies in some cases which means that
it is a much more important part of
their delivery but i share your
frustration on many occasions
exactly um just a final thought let's
end where we started should we um tory
voters support nationalizing energy
firms at least in the short term that
according to a yougov uh poll 47 almost
half of tory voters that were asked said
that we should nationalize the energy
firms for now what do you think well i
think the way that the market has been
regulated hasn't worked as well as it
could have done in the interests of
consumers i think that what we've got to
see is some improvement in a host of
issues for me i'm not sure whether
nationalization does anything other than
borrow a huge amount of money today in
order to buy companies that will then
have to pay back that borrowing through
taxation so for me it doesn't work but i
understand the frustration that is at
the back of that uh suggestion and i
think we need to address the concerns
that people have rather than necessarily
using that to address those concerns
well
as i say it's partly about uk energy
security it's partly about investing in
nuclear for instance you've got the
chancellor over in the us today talking
about how we can make sure that nuclear
is a greater part of our energy mix
we've got to try and tackle what is a
long-standing problem in a lot of
different ways okay minister it's great
to talk to you thank you for joining us
this morning really appreciate it thank
you a quick look at the papers for you
the ft financial times says the eu is to
unveil crisis action on energy including
decoupling electricity prices from the
soaring cost of gas
the eye has an exclusive claiming that
liz trust cost of living plan is being
delayed because her camp hasn't received
enough information from treasury
officials
the express describes mistrust's tax
plan as the only way to rescue the
economy
according to the times the tory
leadership frontrunner plans to approve
new oil and gas drilling licenses in the
north sea
the guardian warns of potential school
closures after top conservatives warn
soaring energy costs could lead to the
school week being
reduced the metro reports ombre is
demanding help with energy bills warning
without support many won't survive
more now on the met launching a murder
investigation after a 21 year old man
stabbed to death at the notting hill
carnival in london sabbas there for us
hi saba tell us more morning
good morning kay as you say a murder
investigation is
underway a 21 year old man and was
attending the knot and kill carnival
here in west london
where he was
stabbed now police were made aware of a
stabbing incident at around 8 p.m
last night and paramedics arrived at the
scene shortly afterwards they had to
walk through uh crowds of people with
great difficulty there were hundreds of
people in the area the young man was
taken to a local hospital shortly
afterwards where he was pronounced dead
now uh there was a section 60 order that
was issued shortly after the incident
and essentially what this means is that
police aren't able
to arrest to stop and search people um
without suspicion now the family of this
young man have been made aware of
his death and are also
he is being
assisted by specialist officers now sky
news earlier spoke to
an individual from the metropolitan
police and this is what she had to say
there were hundreds of people in the
immediate vicinity when this incident
took place
i would urge anyone who saw anything who
has video footage or who has any other
information that could assist officers
to come forward
tonight our thoughts are with the family
of the young man who has lost his life
in this senseless attack
there um
the next of kin have been aware as i've
mentioned and police are urgently
calling for members of the public who
were there to come forward with any
video evidence that they may have that
will help this investigation
thank you
in other news president zielenski has
warned russian soldiers that if they
want to survive they should go home
ukraine says it's broken through the
russian front line in several places in
a new counter-offensive deborah stanley
bye for us this morning um hi deborah i
heard you uh breaking this story
yesterday on sky how is it developed
yes so interestingly this morning the uk
and its regular update on the state of
the war has said that they believe that
several ukrainian brigades have
intensified their artillery strikes
since the beginning of yesterday against
russian positions along the south this
is backed up by long-range precision
strikes against russian supply lines and
ammunition depots all part of this
offensive though the uk is keen to
stress that it's not yet possible to
confirm the extent of any ukrainian
advances and it also makes this really
interesting point about how since the
beginning of this month when speculation
has been rife that ukraine was planning
some kind of counter-offensive to
recapture this key region of hassan
particularly the city that's been under
russian control since the beginning that
since the beginning of the months
russian forces have been reinforcing
themselves around that region clearly
preparing to defend themselves they say
that there's been a merger between two
different elements of two different
districts on the russian military side
perhaps an attempt to try to have a
better performance than they displayed
back in the beginning of this war when
they failed so badly in their assault on
kiev clearly whatever happens next will
be decisive to to see whether this
ukrainian advance can achieve some
success
okay thank you
a third of pakistan underwater after
flooding that's killed at least a
thousand people and displaced millions
of others the country's government
described it as a climate-induced
humanitarian disaster of epic
proportions let's speak now to our asia
correspondent cordelia lynch um hi
cordelia this is just horrific
it is okay i mean devastating pictures
coming out of pakistan you see people
trying to traverse these treacherous
waters we've seen bridges
that are completely impassable lots of
the elderly that are trying to cross
wading through the water more than 1 100
people dead now okay the
governments say a third of those are
children people are living in makeshift
camps trying to get their hands on what
little food they can the governments say
that it is
certainly a climate change catastrophe
and a man made one there is discussion
about who ultimately
helps fund support for this and where
that money should potentially come from
pakistan's already been suffering
financially they've been looking
at a bailout from the international
monetary fund recently this will only
add to their woes and what we're seeing
is a whole confluence of things you've
had this heavy rain over two months the
likes of which the country hasn't seen
since those devastating floods of 2010
add to that melting glaciers as well and
some people say that that local
government is culpable in this that
hotels were able to build on and cut off
these river routes that means that the
water's been redirected
into villages there's been some
miraculous
recoveries people being rescued and
winched up from helicopters in really
mountainous areas but it is
an incredibly difficult situation for
people there with no immediate end in
sight this is going to be deeply costly
they're already saying
well i think we may have lost um
cordelia for now we will return
to that story later on in the program of
course a thousand people having died a
third of pakistan is said to be under
water and the authority is blaming
climate change as a result of that
here's our
dashboard and
many of you will have seen it a couple
of times already by now this week um the
top left-hand side that's the figure
that we use how much warmer the planet
is since 1880 up by 1.25 degrees and
counting co2 emissions in millions of
tons that according to the university of
oxford then on the right hand side you
can see um how much fuel uh a real-time
power mix we're using at the moment so
the amount of fuel that we're using
almost 55 of that is coming from our gas
supply at the moment we're importing two
percent of our fuel and on we go
still to come on the program for you
soon we'll be talking to a young
pakistani climate activist about the
floods the disaster that has all the
hallmarks of a climate emergency
at 20 to 8 we'll speak to a brewery boss
who's warning that his industry is being
crippled by rocketing costs
and just after that the mayor of greater
manchester that's andy burnham will tell
us about a costal living rally they'll
be at today's so-called enough is enough
rally
at least 15 protesters have been killed
after violence broke out in the iraqi
capital of baghdad after an influential
shia cleric announced he was stepping
away from politics muktara al-sadr's
party won the largest share of seats in
last october's parliamentary elections
but refused to negotiate with rivals
leading to months of political deadlock
mr al-sadr's resignation
prompted hundreds of his supporters to
storm the government palace
police in liverpool have made more than
30 arrests in 24 hours as part of a
crackdown on organized crime following
the fatal shooting of olivia pratt
corbell merseyside police have also
carried out over 60 stop-and-searches
and seized eight vehicles
research out today shows 474 gp
surgeries have closed in the uk since
2013 leaving 1.5 million patients having
to go elsewhere gp magazine
pulse says smaller practices have been
far more likely to shut down and these
are the ones patients prefer
people in parts of scotland face yet
another day without bin collections
after talks between unions and local
authorities once again collapsed gmb and
unite have rejected the latest pay deal
so as it stands two-thirds of scotland's
councils will be on strike for the
second round of industrial action next
week
the bosses of six of the uk's biggest
pub and brewery companies have written
an open letter to the government they
warn of mass closures if the industry
doesn't help with energy bills our
business correspondent paul kelso has
spoken to one worried pub owner
we're certainly looking at probably 250
to 300 percent increase in electric and
gas over the next six months
but the red line in qrikelade the energy
bills are going up as the pints slip
down
we're around about two thousand pound a
month give or take for uh electricity
that's going to go up to about a
thousand pound a week
tenant landlord darren is among
thousands of publicans worried that
rising energy costs for his business
suppliers and customers might hasten
last orders
covered was tough
but it's i don't think it's going to be
anything as tough as what we've got
coming
um you know at least during covert we
could still do our which we did our
takeaways and all that sort of thing but
that now that's all out of our hands now
it's uh it's all down to prices way way
way way above us
six of the uk's largest pub and brewing
companies have written to ministers
warning that without help many of their
tenants may be calling time this winter
it comes as new figures show four in ten
hospitality businesses say energy prices
are their biggest worry with two-thirds
having already been affected by rises
and over half absorbing extra costs
we're desperately calling for action
from the government to give us an energy
cap for small businesses and to do a
long-term plan with hospitality so we
can save pubs and borrowers at the heart
of our communities by making sure
they're taking action to give them a
central headroom like cutting vat
business rates and of course keeping
beer duty low
the government says energy prices are
beyond its control and pubs have
benefited from rape relief and duty
freezes on beer cider and wine but as
the sun sets on a vintage beer garden
summer they see little reason for cheer
paul kelso sky news
let's get more now on ukraine's
offensive to try to push russian forces
back in the south of the country and
retake the city of kerzen ed arnold is a
research fellow at the royal united
services institute rusi uh the acronym
and is with us now hello to mr arnold
thanks for joining us on the program
what's going on with kerzen
so at the moment uh yesterday the
ukrainian government announced the
decisive phase of their
counter-offensive we've been
expecting this for a number of months
and the shaping or preparatory activity
has been ongoing for around two months
where ukraine has targeted russian
positions ammunition supplies to try and
degrade their artillery strengths and
also bridges over the nipah river which
is just to the east of the coast of
kirsan city so now what we're going to
try to
expect to see is a large-scale ukraine
counter-offensive to take at least the
city of kirsan and potentially
more territory to the east of the river
into the region so why is kirsten so
important
well kirsten's important because
politically it was one of the first
places taken by the russian forces at
the start
in february and also politically
significant because the ukrainian
government and president zelinski has to
show the west that he is able to use all
of these western supplied weapon systems
to actually take back territory so that
is really important and at the moment
once curson at least the city is in
ukrainian control that means that
there's no russian forces to the north
or west of the nipah river which
essentially dissects the whole of
ukraine it protects mikolayev and
podesta further down the coast it puts a
lot of pressure on russian forces in the
south and particularly crimea and part
of that roadway if you will down to
crimea
exactly that sort of start to push
russian forces
back um
ukraine had significant victories in the
early part of the war they were then
under a lot of pressure in the east in
the last four months so this would be a
very uh strategic win for ukraine and
obviously in terms of the time frames
not that
war fighting will completely end during
the winter but
during the months in the next sort of
three months the war will start to
subside so ukraine needs to show that
they can take back territory now and
secure that western support for ongoing
offenses that will happen over the
coming years
what do you say that obviously fighting
will stop hunter hand fighting on the
ground we'll stop but shelling of
nuclear plants may well continue how
concerned are we about that
very concerned at the moment and
president zielinski messaged last week
to say that he was very concerned in
terms of the reactors
the iaea from a team from the u.n is
deployed to ukraine at the moment to try
and get to the site to essentially
assess the safety of it but the
ukrainian population are obviously very
concerned they've started to give iodine
tablets out to
civilians within the area so that is one
issue that the international community
is very concerned about as this
counter-offensive starts in the south
and as far as the iaea is concerned i
mean we heard about them a lot during
the um iraq war we haven't heard so much
about them particularly in the headlines
um too much of late
international atomic energy agency i
heard a representative speaking on the
radio over the weekend saying this is
probably the toughest gig they've ever
had including iraq
well it's very difficult and also they
are going into a live conflict zone a
lot of the um nuclear assessments that
they usually do are not in the conflict
zone so it's going to be very difficult
to actually get the teams in there and
also whether russia will try and stall
to get the teams in there at the moment
you know it's russian forces that have
the safari region nuclear power plants
at the moment and essentially using it
as a potent potentially a political
bargaining tool and being quite
obstructive sure what's their job if and
when they do get in
well they need to assess the plans
to check its structural integrity check
what the risk is because at the moment
we just do not know they need to
understand how they can try and isolate
the plant from the wider wall because
essentially if something happens with
that the reactor and the plant that's
going to be very very destructive for
ukraine as a whole and the subsequent
support that would be needed to ukraine
again in a war zone will be incredibly
difficult so the international
community's focus really now is trying
to stabilize that plant and ultimately
trying to create a ring around it so
military forces can leave and then more
civilian personnel can come in to
stabilize that plan and just to clarify
before i let you go that is the re
within the remit of the iaea they can
say okay we need to neutralize this area
guys
no they can recommend it what would then
need to happen is probably starting with
the un but ultimately trying to find a
body that can
have a resolution to try and create a
demilitarized zone around that you know
again these are all very difficult
conversations it might have to be
protected by another military force
which would be again very difficult
obviously un sits on russia sits on the
u.n security council so these are some
of the issues that are going to drag on
for the the coming months again with a
large-scale counter-offensive happening
in the south so it's a very critical
time good to talk to you thanks very
much indeed for coming in much
appreciated thank you
still to come on the programme for you
we'll have all today's top stories um
and indeed the very latest on the cost
of living crisis do stay tuned
hello again everybody you're watching
the breakfast show here on sky news
tuesday morning top stories police have
launched a murder investigation after a
21 year old man was stabbed to death
during a violent end to the notting hill
carnival
government minister matt warman says
more needs to be done to deal with the
cost of living crisis insisting it will
be at the top of the next prime
minister's entry
ukraine says it's broken through the
russian front line in several places
during a long-awaited counter-offensive
russia though says it repelled the
assault
early this morning rishi sunax supporter
and culture minister matt warman told
sky news that the vulnerable be a
priority this winter but concedes help
will be needed across the board
what they're saying is that they're
worried about the uncertainty of what
winter is going to look like and of
course they've seen those headlines
about the new
cap i think for me the most important
thing is that we target those who need
it most we target the most vulnerable
that's what you saw in that package that
differentiates between some people who
have greater needs than others but
acknowledge that everybody needs help
but when tomorrow
well not yet not till the next prime
minister is in which is now uh next
monday so not that long to go but i
think the concern even being openly
admitted by ministers is that the public
have been left in limbo knowing where
energy bills are going but not what
support they will get from either
contender he was saying the minister
there who's supporting rishi sunak that
whoever gets in will bring more help
with them perhaps that is a sign that
rishi senate supporters are now
reconciling themselves to what the
outcome is expected to be which is that
liz truss is expected to to triumph next
week what sort of support neither side
have really said there are various ideas
coming out of the trust camp over the
weekend including a cut in vat which of
course would not be targeted at the
poorest people so little sense there
about what she's planning the minister
there said people like pensioners and
those on fixed incomes like benefits
will need some help but he also talked
about further up the income spectrum but
not where that line would be drawn so
still very much in the dark with
suggestions by the liz trust camp that
they don't know enough yet from the
treasury to make those sorts of
decisions so the next prime minister
will be in place before we know the
current chancellor nadeem zahawi is
going to washington this week and he
will be talking to u.s treasury
officials and central bankers about
international solutions to the energy
crisis how far that will get him when
he's not expected to be in a job by next
week is not clear and labour say he
should start by listening to people here
at home yes sir already i think talking
about nuclear opportunities uh but
interesting the minister suggesting that
actually as far as he was concerned the
race for the next prime minister has
taken too long yes that was interesting
of course the timetable set by the
conservative party's 1922 committee and
because it was running over the summer
perhaps the suggestion is that it was
let run too long and he certainly said
it would be something for the party to
pick up next time this idea that
spending weeks being buffeted by events
especially when you've got this cost of
living crisis already setting in is
something to learn from in the future
and perhaps is not reflected well on the
conservative party either in terms of
how far the two candidates have attacked
each other or just how long it has left
the country in limbo for i thought that
was pretty strong indication that he
certainly thought it was too long yeah
blowing in the wind uh we'll see you for
tomorrow's take at nine o'clock look
forward to it thank you now to a warning
that pubs could be closing their doors
for good the heads of six of the largest
pub and brewing companies have warned
that the industry urgently needs
government support or faces mass
closures and irreversible damage due to
rising energy prices andrew turner
he's the chief operating officer at the
scent hostile brewery he's with us now
hi it's good to see you thanks for
joining us on the program how bad is it
uh yeah it's uh it's gonna potentially
be pretty catastrophic is the word you
said um you know unlike consumers uh
there is no uh energy price cap for
small businesses
and therefore we're seeing spiraling
costs for our tenants for our pubs for
our breweries right across the industry
you know totally wiping out the profits
they're making which questions why on
earth that they would bother to open the
doors going forward
you know it's really disappointing that
the government well positive the
government supported us through the
through the pandemic um and we got
through that and we got through that in
a fairly good state
and now we're facing another crisis and
you know without further support all the
good work that happened during the
pandemic isn't going to be completely
unwound
so what do you need the next prime
minister to do to help you guys
it'll be helpful to uh to have somebody
at the top first of all to make some
decisions uh that would be the first uh
the first step but what we're asking for
is an energy price cap for small
businesses uh and we're asking for for
grants uh to support many of the pubs up
and down the country you'll remember
when people think about pubs you just
think about walking into a pub and
having a pint uh but these are also the
hearts of you know many communities uh
important for the sort of social fabric
that the uk has grown up on and also
these people it's not just their
businesses for many for many of them
it's their homes um and and whilst they
live upstairs again they do not get the
benefit of a consumer price cap um so
you know it is it is really serious for
for communities for republicans and for
small businesses
how does it compare
to uh the challenges during the pandemic
or does this just compound what you're
already seeing over the last couple of
years
yeah it's been a pretty uh it's been a
pretty tough couple of years two and a
half years for the industry
um i think we came out of it pretty well
again thanks to the government's support
um we were rebuilding um you know poster
pandemic
at the moment it feels like we're
sat in the ether a bit clearly there is
no significant leadership at the top to
make decisions again you know we need
that to happen so that we can we can
have some decisions made at the moment
you know the the energy
prices firing we had an example uh last
week
where one of our tenants
saw over a 400
increase
uh in their energy bills and it just
wipes out any profit they are making i
mean as i said before it's just just
there's no point in uh opening the doors
uh so it feels at the moment we're a bit
in the dark um and we need government to
step forward to make some decisions to
support our sector uh and keep what is a
you know what is a
cornerstone of the uk uh business
um going going over this this tough time
yes it's it's an another situation
unfortunately like
[Music]
completely outside of our control
it's good to talk to you thanks for
joining us on the program this morning
thank you
thanks gary
thanks a lot the royal navy's largest
aircraft carrier which sailed from
portsmouth yesterday following delays
due to technical problems has broken
down off the coast of the isle of wight
as we said over the weekend divers
inspecting hms prince of wales with
reports suggesting the vessel's
propeller shaft is damaged the ship was
just hours into a landmark mission to
the us when she broke down here's sadia
a three billion pound warship the pride
of the royal navy
but for most of bank holiday monday hms
prince of wales was stranded off the
south
coast shortly after the ship sailed on
saturday a mechanical fault was
discovered with the starboard shaft
i've been to the ship today to see for
myself what the issue is and how we in
the royal navy can work together to make
sure that the ship can successfully
return to her tasking
after an initial assessment it's likely
the fault will require repairs which may
impact the ship's program
this was the vessel's celebratory
departure on saturday delayed by a day
due to a technical issue
it was then supposed to spend three
months traveling to new york canada and
the caribbean
conducting training exercises with the
navy's western atlantic counterparts
we're about five miles off the coast and
there she is a 65 000 ton warship the
hms prince of wales is one of the navy's
most prized vessels and now in need of
repair
it's always embarrassing when one of
your major fleet units breaks down i
don't think
we know the extent of what has happened
yet as
i think we've seen it may be a major or
minor fault
we don't like our warships coming out of
the front line if you like to be
rectified several smaller boats appear
to be involved in the vessels returned
to a different anchorage where the navy
says further inspections can take place
sadia chowdhury sky news on the isle of
wight
the chancellor nadim zahawi is traveling
to the u.s this week to meet with
american bankers and officials to work
on joint solutions to the cost of living
crisis the treasury says they'll discuss
energy security financial services and
soaring prices
at home abortion pills will be made
permanently available to women in
england and wales from the end of the
month so-called pills by post were made
temporarily available at the start of
the pandemic
good news for tea drinkers those who
have more than two cups a day are likely
to live longer than non-tea drinkers
that's according to a study published in
the annals of internal medicine goodness
which find positive effects no matter
whether you take it black with milk or
with sugar
nasa says a second attempt at the
artemis one moon rocket launch is still
possible this friday the first test
flight of a project to send humans back
to the moon was postponed yesterday due
to a problem with one of its engines
here's devi blevins from cape canaveral
this is artemis launch control with an
update launch director charlie blackwell
thompson has called a scrub
for today history will have to wait just
three minutes into the launch window she
made the call
huge disappointment for those gathered
along the space coast for a glimpse of
artemis won i'm pretty bummed i drove
from minnesota
but i had a backup plan you know we're
at the beach can't complain how
disappointed are you
very because it's my birthday
this sucks
you traveled 10 hours to get here yes 10
hours from alabama so how big a deal is
this for you it's a huge [ __ ] it was
like the biggest rocket ever you've got
artemis t-shirts you must be really into
this project yes we are is it that
excites you about it is it the fact that
it's a woman will go to the moon
absolutely person who's absolutely color
going to the movie absolutely i think
that's huge especially for our children
you know just to see something like that
the vice president kamila harris had
already arrived at kennedy space center
hoping to witness america's first step
towards putting humans back on the moon
but a fuel leak and engine conditioning
issues grounded the spacecraft on launch
pad 39b this is a brand new rocket
it's not going to fly until it's ready
spaceflight is risky
that's what you do
you buy down that risk you make it as
safe as possible and of course
that is
the whole reason for this test flight
the artemis program aims to put the
first woman and first person of colour
on the moon by 2025 and establish a
permanent base there from which humans
might one day visit mars
it will be the most consequential launch
in a generation
when it happens
this is about learning about how one day
we can go further and that is the
exciting thing whether or not we use the
moon as a base
or what's called a gateway a sort of a
spacecraft that's in orbit around the
moon we can use
those two
parts of this artemis mission to learn
much more about what we need to do
this launch has been 10 years in the
making so what's another few days when
you need 8.8 million pounds of thrust to
lift a spacecraft off the ground
everything has to be just right
if it isn't
they'll be wasting billions of dollars
writing a new chapter in space
exploration is a costly business
they'll be hoping this is one small
delay and not one giant setback
david blevins sky news at cape canaveral
florida
now we see what he did there and they're
going to try again as david was saying
on friday of course we'll update you as
soon as we have more on that i think
there's another window on monday after
that and then not for quite a long time
sean the sheep is waiting in
anticipation apparently he's going to be
on board
we'll have more on that as i said in the
coming hours and days more now on the
cost of living crisis which is engulf
the country and the tory leadership
campaign joining us now is the mayor of
greater manchester andy burnham hello to
you mr burnham thank you for joining us
on the program this morning you're
taking part in a rally i think today
called enough is enough it has been
criticized for being too broad what is
it
well i think those words okay enough is
enough for words that uh many many
people in greater manchester
are using right now i've been going
around this weekend i was at a homeless
charity yesterday people are scared
people are genuinely scared
about what's coming
and when they look around they don't see
how things are fair you know they kind
of see the cost of the essentials water
gas electric buses trains you know guns
gone through the roof they see the
bosses of those companies getting
massive payouts
and the workers people who work within
those organizations haven't got enough
to live on i think people are starting
to question
a lot basically of how things have been
organized in this country in recent
years and they want change i think the
public are ahead of the politicians
actually that they're ahead of it in
terms of seeing the scale of the cost of
living crisis but also the change that's
needed if we're to get get through it
fairly and that's what tonight's rally
is about i'll be pleased to welcome it
to manchester because you know from my
point of view i start with the residents
of greater manchester they are looking
for people to speak up for them and to
call for the big change that's needed
and that's what they're hearing from the
enough is enough campaign
who do you expect to attend
lots of people are coming actually all
walks of life i think it's something
that is capturing the sort of moment um
as i say we need uh people to to wake up
to the scale of this and i think that's
the call we'll be going out from from
tonight
um and you know i i would say to to all
my colleagues in west westminster my old
colleagues i think we need to start
approaching the cost of living crisis
like we did the early stages of the
pandemic
where the parties came together and
started to think of interventions that
perhaps they wouldn't think of in normal
times where key workers were
recognized and properly respected and
rewarded you know i heard a conservative
mp mr gullis on the media of the weekend
demonizing greedy rail workers in his
words well i'm sorry but that is just
not good enough these are the people
that he was clapping that everyone was
clapping a few years ago you know we
need to to recognize that people are
going to need fair pay rises if they're
going to keep britain running through
what is going to be a really challenging
time
um you are of course happy to share the
stage with the union leader mick lynch
would you be happy to share a picket
line with him
i would and you know i don't see this as
you know controversial you know people
are fighting for their incomes
in a cost of living crisis
and so of course you've got to kind of
recognize
the point that they are making they're
going to work but they don't have enough
to live on
and in calling for the party to approach
this like the pandemic i would say
particularly uh to the government and if
it is to be liz trust who's the next
prime minister
get round the table we've had a summer
of you know politicking really you know
making the unions responsible for
everything and you know kind of
all kinds of unhelpful rhetoric you need
to get round the table and there needs
to be sector by sector deals here that
are fair to people but also keep the
country running and if people ask how
that's to be paid for what i would say
okay is we need now to open up a debate
on the culture of high and excessive pay
in the top half of organizations this
has gone on and on and on over the last
couple of decades where the gap between
those at the bottom and those at the top
has just got bigger and bigger there was
research last week that says in the ftse
100 companies on average the pay of
those at the top is 109
times higher than the pay of those at
the bottom i mean that is why people are
saying enough is enough
what about um energy companies and
energy bosses should energy companies in
the uk be private um
nationalize for now take it back into
public ownership
well there's certainly a case for more
public control more public ownership of
essential utilities you know i've
listened to the leadership debate in the
tory party this summer and they've both
been promising more facturism well as
far as i'm concerned that is what got us
into the mess that we're in right now
when we sold off the water sold off the
electricity sold off the gas sold off
the council homes sold off the buses all
of the trains we found ourselves in a
position where ordinary people can't
afford those basics anymore those
essentials and therefore change is
needed in the way that we provide those
essential services everybody needs the
basics everybody needs to be able to
afford the basics and this just isn't
taught okay i've taken the decision to
put buses back under public control in
greater manchester after 36 years of
deregulation on monday this coming
monday we will introduce a fair cap in
greater manchester a cap of two pound on
a single adult fair so we are taking
steps that we can you know the talk that
i've heard this summer of more
deregulation more privatization that has
left us in a position where we've had
chaos on our trains buses that people
can't afford and raw sewage on our
beaches and that is why change is needed
two policies there that you are
completely opposite to what kiyostama
has suggested people on
politicians on the picket lines and then
also the nationalization of the energy
companies you see the right man for the
job
i didn't hear that question i'm sorry
you froze on me there no no no i'm very
sorry i'll i'll say it again tuesday
morning just having my first cup of tea
um and you know what northerners are
like with their tea i was making the
point that um you've two two policies
there that are directly opposite to what
we've heard from sakia's stammer one of
them is about politicians being on the
picket lines he doesn't think that's a
good idea senior politicians which of
course you are and the second one is um
nationalizing energy companies initially
we heard labour thought that was a good
idea and now they seem to have
backtracked is he the right man for the
job was the question yes he is and
i think what you can see is the support
for him in the polls is making that that
clear
he did intervene in the summer uh with
the policy of a price
freeze and that is a very good start i
would say there is a there is a case to
go further as i've said this morning
in terms of you you said i i'm saying
different things well i'm in a different
job i'm not in westminster i've just got
a role to speak up for greater
manchester that's different to any
politician in westminster so i will come
to different judgments as i look at it
right now
when i listen to people in grace monster
who tell me they're scared about what's
coming who tell me that already they've
turned every appliance off in their home
and they're
cooking via their microwave and nothing
else
it's my job to respond to what they're
saying and actually then put forward
policies that i think will support them
there is strong public support what the
enough is enough campaign is saying on
all of the policies that they're that
they're putting forward and it's my job
if you like from the outside to speak up
for the residents of greater manchester
everyone always thinks that whenever you
do anything it's an internal political
game well it's not i think we're beyond
any kind of time for those kind of those
kind of things this is a massive crisis
the scale of which we've not faced
before it will require politicians to do
different things to intervene in markets
to protect people and it's really
important that i use my voice to to say
that and hopefully give people the the
space to come forward
and work out plans that will get the
country through this
do you support people joining don't pay
uk
well
at this stage is definitely a step that
i wouldn't support you know we've got to
live within the rule of law haven't we
we've got to um keep keep a country
where um you know people respect
um the the norms and respect the way of
doing things i understand why people are
saying it but i wouldn't in any way
recommend that that's that's the way
that people people should go what we
need is
action to make things affordable for
people uh but i do feel that kind of
call will increase unless we see the
scale of action that is going to be uh
going to be needed
uh paul franks has emailed me this
morning just before i let you guys this
morning kay can you ask andy burnham
would he consider running for leader of
the labour party then ultimately prime
minister regards paul
i have said one day if that were ever uh
something that that um would be
something people would support but not
now uh because um we've got a leader of
the labour party who is providing
leadership in the cost of living crisis
and i'm happy uh to give my full support
to care and i've got a job to do in
greater manchester okay you know i am
making big changes to public transport
which hopefully will help people uh
through this uh and that's where my full
focus is right now
but you're not ruling it out there are
you
i've just been honest i i mean in the
future you know i've got i've said i'll
serve a full second term as mayor of
base manchester if at some point beyond
way beyond at this point where we are
that that was something that was a
possibility i would consider it but i
i'm just focused on what i'm doing right
now we're putting in place a whole range
of support to help people
through this through this crisis that
should be the sole focus of politicians
right now i think
the people who are vying to be leader of
the tory party the ones that need to be
answering questions right now you know
they've spent the summer i think in a
comfort zone talking to their own party
giving them the kind of answers they
want to hear but actually those are the
things that got us into this mess in the
first place and i think if it is to be
liz trust she will need to make some big
big changes and big moves very quickly
if she is she is to come into this role
and help the country through this so
it's not about the future now is it it's
about today and who's going to give
people the reassurance that they're
looking for yeah a nice sort of body
swerve at the end there uh the wigan's
front row would be proud of you it's
good to talk to you thanks very much
indeed
wherever you go
[Music]
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
next few days mostly fine turning
unsettled to end the week
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
just want to show you this
it's all gravy they're just missing some
giant yorkshire pudding to go with this
giant pool of gravy men and women came
to wrestle at the world gravy wrestling
championships in lancashire yesterday
look at them yeah northern boys love
gravy we'll see you at the top of the
hour
[Music]